I made the decision to make this my last
season as co-host with Kell here on Live
with Kelly and Ryan which is Bittersweet
Ryan Seacrest's girlfriend Aubrey page
celebrates her man on social media just
days before announcing he's leaving Live
with Kelly and Ryan this show
has a unique charm I've actually
genuinely excited to see her every
morning and that might be part of the
magic on Thursday Ryan surprised the
audience with some unexpected news he's
stepping down from the morning show
after six seasons and Kelly Ripa's
husband Mark Consuelos will take over
the gig the only person I can think of
that is capable of you know holding
holding your torch the way you have held
it and that would be my husband Ryan's
plan moved back to Los Angeles to focus
on American Idol and Dick Clark's New
Year's Rockin Eve a decision which will
also put him closer to his girlfriend a
few days before the big announcement
Aubry shared a loving message to Ryan on
Valentine's Day posting a montage of
picks alongside a caption that read in
part loving you has been the adventure
of a lifetime cheers to many more laughs
sunrises meals and spontaneous
Adventures blessed to have the honor of
loving his it makes you really smile the
two have been dating since 2021 and have
kept their relationship pretty private
aside from a few red carpet appearances
I have to say that it is a rare thing to
work with a guy who is so authentic and
fun and joyful and humble and generous
and kind to everyone on Thursday
following the news of his departure from
live the TV personality shared a special
message for The Other Woman in his life
his co-host Kelly Ripa writing on
Instagram that he'll miss his work wife
to work with this amazing individual is
an incredible thing and I learned so
much from her not just by being on the
air but about life with Ryan exiting the
show will be rebranded to Live with
Kelly and Mark with Kell's longtime love
and frequent guest co-host getting
promoted to full time good morning
and on Thursday Mark wrote on Instagram
that he knows he has some big shoes to
fill and I'm excited about it and when
it comes to her hubby Kelly joked on
Instagram welcome home or to the
contractual obligation phase of our
relationship
foreign